sûr parler de sérieux on va parler des
émissions de télé c'est le deuxième
sujet du jour vous restez avec nous en
tenir vraiment avec plaisir
quasiment tous les métiers tous les
secteurs d'activité sont touchés avec
leur confinement évidemment la
télévision n'échappe pas à cette règle
regarder mon art public virtuel par
exemple et les nouvelles mesures
pourraient complètement bouleversé les
grilles des programmes
on parle bien sûr de danse avec les
stars miss france nrj music awards on se
demande quel est l'avenir de ces
émissions télé ce qu'elles vont avoir
lieu ou pas regardez alors que de
nombreuses chaînes avaient décidé de
décaler leurs émissions phares durant le
premier confinement certaines devaient
avoir justement lieu en ce moment mais
avec le second confinement d'urgence qui
s'est déclaré c'est la panique si les
tournages de séries de films et
d'émissions de télé sont autorisés
durant ce confinement difficile pour
autant de mettre en place des émissions
à grand spectacle qui nécessite de
grandes équipes techniques et du public
c'est par exemple le cas de danse avec
les stars qu'il devrait pas revenir à
l'antenne prochainement pour danse avec
les stars c'est si la situation perdure
je pense que l'on pourra pas le faire
rapidement il faudra qu'on le deccan un
petit peu plus tard dans l'année mais
ont d'autres formats tf1 a décidé
d'organiser coûte que coûte les
tournages c'est le cas des nrj music
awards qui devraient avoir lieu en
décembre mais dans des conditions
inédites si la cérémonie se déroule
habituellement en direct du festival de
cannes c'est cette année à paris que
l'émission devrait avoir lieu dans des
conditions adaptées c'est à dire
vraisemblablement son public et avec des
tournages qui seront bien séparés les
uns des autres
quant à l'élection de miss france qui
devait se dérouler depuis le puy du fou
tf1 est pour le moment incapable de
trancher alors d'als nm à miss france
les émissions doivent-elles être
maintenue alors miss france c'est très
compliqué d'abord il ya une élection qui
n'a pas pu avoir lieu c'est miss rhône
alpes qui a été retardé je sais je
m'étais je me bats je m'étais voilà
j'étais je suis arrivée la porte était
fermée monde y restons belimo d'accord
et puis la soeur de marine l'orphelin
louane qui est miss bourgogne et comme
sa soeur est positive donc elle ne sait
pas si elle pourra s'y rendre
il ya plein d'autres exemples comme ça
réunir toutes ces miss en plus en
grandes pompes parce qu'ils veulent
faire une immense cérémonie avec les
anciennes miss ça me paraît très
compliqué sylvie tellier essaye mais je
ne suis pas sûr les a élus d'accord la
patrie isabel coixet que l'animateur est
là bas
ces machines mettez votre carte là bas
merci les nrj music awards pour moi
c'est non nos francs je suppose qu'on
essaye de la façon d'une eau très bas
très bien ou vice et nous on va tout
faire on va tout faire pour moi c'était
avec miss france se fasse que l'énergie
est pas pourquoi mais bon vous
comprendrez juifs et j'ai compris moi
pour caspar n'a compris mais il faut il
faut évidemment là délaissés pour les
gens qui regardent la télévision c'est
ma prison qui assistent au spectacle
donc il faut pas qu'ils pensent en
termes de ballades public il vit pense à
ceux qui bossent au cadreur à tous ceux
qui ont la chance de pour encore causé
la télévision il faut surtout pas
arrêter ça ma part en plus arrêter et
empêcher les gens de bosser vraiment pas
moi je suis pas d'accord avec toi parce
que si j'ai eu un moment où là c'est
justement le fait de de faire travailler
les gens ensemble qui vont faire que on
va encore avoir des malades et on va
encore avoir des problèmes
donc moi je pense que ces démissions
qu'on peut pas faire tout simplement
parce que dans tous les cas il faut
l'énergie du public pour faire ce genre
d'émission ce que nous savons être là
vont défiler devant personne son pull
bien chaud public serait compliqué
gilbert avec tous les concerts sont en
ce moment annulée
bah oui les spectacles au spectacle pour
ce soir mais une exception nrj music
awards suis entièrement d'accord avec
kelly d'où est ce que des gens
pourraient se substituer à ces artistes
qui ne peuvent pas faire de spectacle
vivant mais moi je trouverais ça on
tourne mal à moi je suis comme il a en
fait miss france je veux bien laisser
mais les gens d'aimer tout donner pour
laisser miss france
je trouve ces différents et sa règle
rejoint kelis et c'est vrai que c'est
pour les gens qui regardent le public
dont miss france il est moins important
le public des concerts déjantés les gens
mais c'est chez eux mais le public ni
par pourtant dans la salle dans les nrj
music awards qui aura pas de stars
internationales déjà y avait pas avant
déjà si si si si loin à 6,6 il ya eu
baby sharks mais là ça va être ça est un
peu fade je pense donc je suis pas moi
j'aurais pas mis les énergies on peut le
décalé prochaine l'énergie - garde les
miss france et battre est bien là
écoutez on va faire on va voir ce qu'on
va faire je vous dis que je voulais dire
des philippines est rien du tout je ne
suis pas d'accord je là pour le coup je
je trouve que d'interdire des spectacles
et des le spectacle gens comme le disait
gilles je vois pas pourquoi on
autoriserait les nrj music awards ça
fait sens effectivement comme vous je
pense qu'il faut cadrer les durs faut
que la télé dur mais la télé dans sa
configuration effectivement fait pour
regarder la télé en vente aussi au
premier le nom finit confinement on sait
on sait jouer de rester polis on s'est
ennuyé comme c'est pas possible vous
avez fait le truc zoom ont été le
premier tout le monde nous a pompé
après cyril lignac il a enchaîné avec
son émission qui était bien mais vous
avez vu pendant le coup finement les les
d'autres qu'on a regardé à la télé et là
vous allez recommencer la même chose
hier c'est de gaulle qui est premier
magellan qu'est premier camp et de
mazinghem leur ai dit d'arrêter des
connards manga après vous vous plaignez
de légende sur les fixes qu'on les
moyens bergame avant la naissance
x qu'est ce qui arrive aux paroisses et
flipper tout le monde personne seulement
en face d'elle fixez-vous des
connaissances maintenant les gens
regardent leur téléphone qu'est-ce qu'il
ya soir à la télé danner d'aller se font
le job c'est magnifique ce que vous avez
fait ce soir